all right so a lot of fans are going to
be very happy as it looks like Kang the
Conqueror is not going anywhere but Dr
Doom still could be entering the MCU and
it looks like Marvel has very specific
plans for both of these characters in
fact we might not even see Kang the
Conqueror again until phase six however
the good news seems to be Kang Dynasty
is going to remain Kang Dynasty the next
Avengers film and Marvel Studios right
now is actually looking to cast Dr Doom
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe And for
those of you wondering if Jonathan
Majors is going to continue to play Kang
the Conqueror in the MCU of course we'll
talk about that today and Marvel Studios
plans for Kang for Doom and for the MCU
moving forward so if you're new be sure
to hit that subscribe buttton so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
Marvel Cinematic Universe News also if
you subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series
X some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner picks one item we pick
one winner at the end of each month only
2 days left this month so be sure to
subscribe and leave a comment so
yesterday it was announced by deadline a
huge media Outlet very reputable most of
you have heard of them by now they
announced that Loki Creator Michael
Waldren to write Marvel studios's
Avengers the King Dynasty this is
interesting for a lot of different
reasons but one of the reasons is we
recently heard a report that Jeff lovess
and Michael wal were both both taken off
both Avengers projects Jeff lovess was
originally supposed to write the King
Dynasty and Michael Waldren originally
supposed to write Avengers Secret Wars
and Marvel originally had them on these
projects very intentionally Jeff lovess
wrote Ant-Man and the WASP Quantom Mania
which introduced to us for the very
first time the true king the Conqueror
not he who remains or another variant
but King himself and in this movie they
also made sure to give us a tiny glimpse
of what he has done before and what is
to come when Janet touched his time
chair and Saul into the past we saw what
he did he has already conquered and
destroyed a bunch of different worlds
and we know that he's defeated many
Avengers then in the post credit scene
we saw what is to come a bunch of
different variants of Kang and the Kang
Trio the Council of Kings am mortis
ramut and the Scarlet Centurion so
having Jeff lovess introduce them and
then writing the next film with Kang the
film that literally has to do everything
with Kang the Kang Dynasty made sense
however ever Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania didn't exactly do too well
and wasn't exactly received Too Well by
the fans either and Marvel Studios has
been struggling lately so it seems like
since they are right now attempting to
make everything better that they are
producing it seemed like they decided to
cut both of the writers to bring in new
writers with fresh ideas who weren't
attached to previous projects because
Michael Waldren wrote Loki season 1 and
he wrote Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness however that
report was only partially true Jeff
lovess is no longer writing the King
Dynasty y but Michael Waldren is still
writing Avengers Secret Wars and now he
is also writing Avengers the King
Dynasty and I think this is actually a
good move I think it's a great idea to
have one writer for both of these movies
the same thing goes with a director for
the movies which they are searching for
right now I think it's a great idea to
have one for both much like Avengers
Infinity war and Avengers endgame we had
the same directors and writers for both
and they both turned out extremely well
so I think for continuity purposes
having the same writer and director
makes sense so Michael Waldron's going
to write both and there's been talks of
Sam Ry possibly coming in to direct
Secret Wars and maybe also the King
Dynasty side note there's also been
reports about Marvel Studios possibly
wanting him back to direct Dr Strange 3
however there's a little bit of a
conflict cuz they also want him for one
of the next Avengers movies or both and
that would be a lot to take on but the
great news to come from this new
announcement is that Avengers King
Dynasty is still Avengers King Dynasty
there was worries that they were going
to get rid of Kang Dynasty altogether
and they were actually going to kind of
cut Kang out of the MCU however this
confirms that they're not they are going
to indeed keep Kang as a main character
and the main big bad of the MCU however
it looks like we're not really going to
see much of him anytime soon according
to Alex Perez from the cosmic circus.com
he states that Kang is still plan to be
the main villain of the Multiverse Saga
but King won't be the main focus of
again until phase six and I think this
really comes down to the state of
Jonathan major right now playing King
the Conqueror as far as we know right
now Jonathan Majors is still Kang the
Conqueror Marvel Studios has not
officially announced anything and
there's obviously some big reasons for
this and there was obviously reasons why
they were talking about bringing Dr
Duman and while they're still talking
about bringing Dr Duman even if it's
just for a side role or a minor role for
the time being of course he'll go on
eventually to become probably the big
bad of the next Saga let's break down
exactly how this is going to happen but
first big thank you to Highland titles
for sponsoring this video before we leap
back into the world of superpowers got
something truly extraordinary for our
Noble listeners imagine that you yes you
can become a lord or lady for just $30
buying a plot of land from Highland
tile.com will allow you to make use of a
Scottish tradition in which land owners
are given a cesy title with more than
15,000 five-star reviews the Highland
titles gift pack is an incredibly
popular gift and the Highland titles app
available from the app and play stores
is a new addition that allows you to
explore a 3D replica of the land choose
the location of your plot and decorate
it using augmented reality embrace the
Majesty as every purchase helps to
conserve the awe inspiring heroic beauty
of the Scottish Wilderness you can soar
into the world of nobility My Friends by
visiting Highland ties.com and become a
lord or lady today use the discount code
Cosmic to receive 25% off your order
that's Highland ties.com and use code
Cosmic so the reason that we probably
aren't going to see Kang until phase six
is most likely because of Jonathan
Major's trial it's still going on right
now and it's probably a little bit away
from being finished we're probably not
that close they've had several meetings
in court already but the actual trial
has yet to begin it actually begins
tomorrow so we'll have an official
update then but Marvel Studios seems to
be waiting to find out what the actual
verdict of this trial is going to be to
find out whether or not Jonathan major
is innocent or guilty and good for them
because one would assume that if he's
innocent then they would keep him as
king the Conqueror but if he's guilty
then they would recast him at this point
it's made very clear that they are
indeed going to recast Kang the
Conqueror and keep Kang as the main
villain of The multivers Saga which
makes perfect sense because if Jonathan
major is found guilty that means he
could face up to a year in prison Marvel
Studios would obviously have to fire him
just because he was guilty but but also
because he would not physically be able
to act anymore he would be in prison now
if he's innocent which everybody is
hoping he is then technically he did
nothing wrong and should not be punished
in any way although he already has been
he's been dropped by management teams PR
teams movies but Marvel Studios is
waiting and this is most likely why Alex
Perez has reported we aren't going to
see him again until phase six Marvel
Studios is waiting to see what happens
and we'll focus their phase five
projects around other things like
building up the new Avengers team that's
something we'll see in Captain America
Brave New World and it does look like
they are kind of going to have somewhat
of a plan B as reports of Dr Doom
entering the MCU are ramping up and
according to The Insider my time to
shine hello zillian Murphy is Marvel's
Top Choice to play Dr Doom in the MCU
and this is awesome because we've
actually already seen some fan art of
him as Dr Doom and he already looks
great and he's an incredible actor from
Batman to Inception to Oppenheimer which
was very recent and he was praised very
highly for for his performance in that
film so this would be an incredible
casting however we are not sure when
exactly he is going to enter the MCU
Alex Perez also stated about doom doom
isn't even more than 15 seconds in
Fantastic 4 if at all in fact many
insiders have reported that they're
unsure right now if Doom will appear in
the Fantastic 4 film so it does kind of
seem like Marvel Studios is getting Doom
ready in case they need to put him in in
phase six depending on what happens with
Jonathan majors and how they feel about
the Kang story line that they're going
to be riding for King Dynasty and Secret
Wars and if they decide not to use him
then hopefully he just goes into the
next Saga which would start with the
next phase phase seven and it does look
like Marvel Studios is indeed going to
keep King with the official announcement
that Michael Waldren will be writing the
Kang Dynasty now of course this could
always change Marvel Studios could
change the title of Kang Dynasty still
however it looks like this is pretty
solidified at this point Kang the
Conqueror is still the main villain of
the Multiverse Saga that is who the
Avengers are going to have to fight him
and all of his variants at least in
secret Wars so go ahead and let me know
your thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe again only 2
days left in the giveaway you can find
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof